y
nuestra gran creación la que nos hace
más ricos más inteligentes más
ecológicos e incluso más felices
así es como el láser catedrático de
economía de la universidad de harvard
describe la ciudad atenas roma venecia
londres o nueva york la ciudad siempre
ha tenido un papel destacado en la
historia del hombre y hoy más de la
mitad de la población de todo el mundo
se concentra en estos espacios
pero cuáles son las ciudades que más que
dejen hoy en visual político contestamos
a esta pregunta
las ciudades estimulan la colaboración
entre las personas la especialización
productiva y la difusión de las ideas se
puede afirmar que ya desde jericó la
ciudad más antigua de la historia en el
concepto de crecimiento económico es
fundamentalmente un concepto urbano no
obstante es en las ciudades donde se han
desarrollado la práctica totalidad de
las innovaciones que han generado la
evolución del ser humano por eso no es
extraño que la concentración de la
población mundial sea una tendencia
creciente según datos de la onu
mientras en 1950 el 30 por ciento de los
habitantes de la tierra vivían en
ciudades en 2015 era el 54 por ciento
casi 4.000 millones de personas sin ir
más lejos la última gran crisis la de
2008 ha afianzado el poder las grandes
urbes como centros económicos y desde
entonces muchas grandes metrópolis han
logrado alcanzar un crecimiento
vertiginoso en eeuu por ejemplo tan sólo
siete áreas metropolitanas nueva york
los ángeles chicago washington dallas y
filadelfia suponen el 25 por ciento de
todo el producto en dineros bruto
nacional
el 2015 el instituto americano brooking
presentó un estudio sobre las 300 urbes
más grandes del mundo con este estudio
perseguía determinar cuáles en las
ciudades que más estaban creciendo trató
de fijarse para ello en dos elementos el
crecimiento económico per cápita y la
capacidad para generar empleo de cada
actividad cabe decir que estas 300 urbes
con apenas el 20 por ciento de la
población de todo el mundo generan casi
la mitad de la economía mundial conforme
al estudio del instituto brookings
este es el particular top five de las
ciudades más prósperas
en quinta posición se sitúa en dubai
una de las pocas ciudades desarrolladas
en los puestos altos del ranking
dubai ha logrado abandonar la
dependencia del petróleo y convertirse
en un centro financiero y comercial a
escala mundial al tiempo que es también
un gran hub logístico para hacernos una
idea de sus logros cabe decir que la
actualidad
dubai está ampliando su capacidad
aeroportuaria para alcanzar los 220
millones de pasajeros anuales el doble
de los que mueve el aeropuerto más
grande del mundo el de atlanta dubai es
famosa por sus excesos en formas de
pistas de esquí en el desierto y las
artificiales y los rascacielos más altos
las siguientes tres posiciones están
ocupadas por ciudades de turquía
ciudades que han conseguido aprovechar
el boom económico que el país turco
registró entre del año 2009 y 2014 así
en cuarta posición se sitúa bursa
también es conocida como la electro dick
turca y es que la ciudad se configura
como un gran clúster de la automoción
donde se realiza el 60 por ciento de la
producción nacional empresas
internacionales como renuncia tiene una
destacada presencia
en tercera posición se sitúa estambul la
mayor área metropolitana del país y
conocido centro turístico comercial y
logístico punto de encuentro histórico
entre asia y europa esta ciudad supone
el 25 por ciento de toda la economía en
segunda posición la también ciudad turca
de esmirna
situada en la costa del mar egeo ha sido
desde el siglo 17 considerada como un
puerto estratégico hecho del que se ha
valido para convertirse en un importante
polo industrial desde la crisis de 2008
es la segunda ciudad del mundo donde más
rápido ha crecido el empleo
y
finalmente en lo más alto del ranking
encontramos la ciudad autónoma de macao
la gran capital mundial del juego
político con 4 millones de seguros aquí
no esté mal le gusta y recogerlo
si así es marcado desplazó ya en 2006 a
las vegas como la capital mundial de los
juegos de azar y en 2014 llegó a
multiplicar por siete toda la
facturación por juego de las velas
el juego enmarcado ha llegado a mover 44
mil millones de dólares al año sin
embargo desde que el instituto brookings
presentó su estudio la economía de macao
se ha enfrentado a un auténtico colapso
con ahora el exceso de inversión la
crisis en china y la guerra que las
autoridades de este país han desatado
contra la corrupción y el lavado de
dinero han propiciado que el producto
interior bruto de macao cayese en 2015
cerca de un 25 por ciento
sí como lo escucháis prácticamente la
misma caída que eeuu registró en los
cuatro años siguientes a la crisis del
29 precisamente para tratar de
relativizar este tipo de fenómenos
burbujas ticos hemos querido fijarnos
también en las ciudades que más han
crecido desde que comenzase el siglo las
ciudades más prósperas desde el año 2000
con un crecimiento anual medio del 11%
de su pib per cápita y del 10 por ciento
en el número de empleos lidera el
ranking mundial la ciudad china de
dongguan situada en el entorno de
influencia de guanzhou esta urbe con más
de 8 millones de habitantes es conocida
por ser una de las fábricas del mundo
además esta ciudad se caracteriza por un
gran contraste demográfico y es que la
relación de mujeres y hombres es de 3 a
1 lo que permite que nos encontremos con
noticias tan sorprendentes como esta en
la ciudad china donde los hombres tienen
hasta tres novias porque hay un montón
de chicas un hombre llegó a explicar en
la televisión local que es más fácil
encontrar una novia que un trabajo un
obrero de fábrica dice que tiene tres
novias y que incluso se conocen entre
ellas le siguen en el top five las
ciudades de jinán su show se amen y vusi
todas ellas ciudades chinas lo que pone
de manifiesto el gran boom económico que
ha registrado este país de hecho tenemos
que descender hasta el puesto 35 para
encontrar la primera ciudad no china
de esta forma dubai o chi ming abu dhabi
delhi y kuwait forman el top five de las
ciudades que más han crecido fuera de
china desde el año 2000
puede que algunas de las piedras que
hemos hablado nos resulten completamente
desconocidas pero lo cierto es que hay
un mundo en marcha que cambia
rápidamente dentro de unos años es más
que probable que muchas de estas
ciudades sean tan famosas como hoy lo
son nueva york londres o tokio un saludo
y hasta el próximo vídeo